too much freedom can be dangerous that's
the message from the UK government which
has unveiled ambitious new plans to
oversee the safest corner of the
internet the country that's famous for
bringing you Mary Poppins is aiming to
be the world's best online nanny we're
putting a legal duty of care on these
companies to keep users safe and if they
fail to do so tough punishments will be
imposed the era of social media firms
regulating themselves is over it's time
to do things differently it's time to
keep our children safe so how is the
British government going to make the UK
the safest place to enjoy the net
well for starters there are going to be
some strict new rules any company that
allows online interaction will be
responsible for their users safety as
well as the content that appears on
their services in the most obvious
examples that will mean purging illegal
material related to terrorist and child
sexual exploitation and abuse and if
companies fail to clean up their act the
likes of Facebook and Twitter will be
put on the naughty step by a new
independent regulator for the Internet
companies will face substantial fines
for failing to pull down dangerous or
extremist materials if the fines don't
work bosses of the offending firms could
be liable to criminal prosecution and if
that fails two websites could be blocked
entirely for UK Internet users and that
regulator should have teeth so we're
going to consult not just on remedial
notices on fines and that can be up to
four percent of global turnover at the
moment none of this is law yet there'll
be 12 weeks of public consultation only
after that draft legislation will be
drawn up but there are already concerns
over the prospect of tough new
regulations there's so much content out
there that can just influence
well really anybody by especially the
younger generation kids I would slightly
maybe disagree I think the Internet is
something which is open and it was
actually a good thing that it was very
always open and not regulated by any any
form of government or whatever I think
it's probably a good idea I think
there's not enough regulation around I
think it's a pretty good idea I think
it's a good idea to have some protection
in there but it depends how stringent
and how close they are to everyday stuff
internet needs better regulation why one
two three four that's why
and then the government says it wants to
remove what it calls harmful content but
who will be the arbiter of what stays up
and what goes down so those social media
companies will have to do two things
first is to set out filters processes
and procedure to show that they are
doing whenever they can in order to
prevent material that could potentially
cause serious harm to young children and
other people and second they will have
to react in a speedy manner to any
request to remove such material at the
moment the government is still deciding
whether the job of regulating should
fall on the shoulders of a new
independent body or an existing one like
broadcast regulator Ofcom and when it
comes to the big social media firms well
like students craving more stringent
discipline Facebook has tentatively
welcomed the plan for greater government
oversight with a caveat or two these are
complex issues to get right and we look
forward to working with the government
and Parliament to ensure new regulations
are effective the UK government says it
wants to be a trailblazer but the
question is how to implement stricter
safety measures without restricting
freedom of the Internet
you